plus haut
[Musique]
oh
mon
[Musique]
au maroc ce n est un cas très très
particulier donc c'est un prédicateur
français qui est sur zone depuis 2013 et
qui a attiré vers la syrie ou vers le
vert le cham
plusieurs djihadistes français donc
certains ont fini dans les rangs de
l'état islamique sont morts dans les
rangs de l'état islamique
d'autres ont participé au 13 novembre et
d'autre même ont été sont rentrés en
france ont été jugés en france
et ils ont fini la peine ils sont
ressortis de prison donc c'est ça
démontre comme m
cette longévité dans la rom san siro
zone qui rentre dans sa septième année
ceci s'explique par le fait qu'il n'est
jamais rentré dans les guerres
fratricides entre factions donc lui-même
il m'a dit que quand à tallinn cham est
entré en conflit avec une autre faction
qui s'appelle asine qui ils sont venus
vers lui pour qu'il rentre dans les
combats contre zoug qui ce qu'il a
refusé de faire
et si on remarque bien on regarde bien
on voit qu'il y rester toujours en
dehors des conflits internes au mouvance
djihadiste rebelles à est libre malgré
le fait qu'il avait sa tête mise à prix
par l'état islamique pendant pendant un
long moment et malgré le fait aussi
qu'il a été emprisonné deux fois par est
alléchant à chaque fois il est il est
ressorti et il a réussi à maintenir ce
ce petit camp en dur aujourd'hui à la
frontière avec la turquie où il ya des
djihadistes certes français mais aussi
des femmes et des enfants
on met en scène mafia mais qu'il a été
contacté par plusieurs transfuges de
l'état islamique essaie de fuir les
derniers réduits de l'état islamique
pour rejoindre libre et re trouvé refuge
au sein de son groupe ce qu'il a refusé
tel qu'il me l'a affirmé y compris
concernant des femmes parce qu'ils
estimaient qu'elle était très radicales
pour intégrer son groupe elle à les
contaminés
son groupe avec leur idéologie tout
simplement parce que c'est le moment où
ils sont au front donc le fait
déterminant était la reprise des combats
est libre et le fait que omar obscènes
et diaby on voit ces combattants sur les
fronts dont son fils donc bilal en scène
le fils de marc homesend diaby était sur
le front au nord de hama
d'autres combattants qui appartient à
son groupe aussi mais aussi sur le
fameux front de saraqeb
et donc c'est comme ça qu'on a eu des
images france 24 les images des combes
roi où on voit ces français au combat
donc c'est à cette occasion aussi
après plusieurs semaines de discussions
que j'ai pu interviewer donc omar en
scène le chef du groupe
deux heures durant peut-être parce qu'on
a eu en france le
le jugement de mourad farès mois de
farez qui était en gros le second de
maromme seine qui l'a remplacé pendant
une période comme ça elle était repartie
aux sénégalais qui a quitté le groupe en
désaccord avec une scène et qui vient
d'être jugé en france donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites à
cependant ce jugement bien sûr le nombre
de mois en faisant est revenu dans la
presse et c'est peut-être à l'aune de
cela que ils ont trouvé opportun de deux
communiqués de parler ou d'accepter en
tout cas de parler à un journaliste
occidental de surcroît français quand
j'ai posé la question à bruxelles pour
le dire pourquoi t'es pas visées par les
frappes de drones a dit pas ce que
j'appelle pas à des attentats en
occident bon ça s'explique peut-être
aussi par le fait qu'il a son camp à la
frontière turque
donc personne n'a envie d'une bavure
avec des missiles qui tombent
côté turc et d'un côté c'est peut-être
vraiment qu'il n'est pas si important
que ça aux yeux des instances
américaines ou françaises ourdou
[Musique]
où